شكرا لميسون واهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه
التغطيه المستمره من العربيه لواحده من
اكبر التطورات في روسيا واوكرانيا منذ
اندلاع الحرب قبل اكثر من عامه واحد من
اهم هذه التطورات وهو استهداف بالطائرات
المسيره خلال الليل للكرملين حيث المجمع
الرئاسي لاكبر قوه نوويه في العالم روسيا
اتهمت اوكرانيا بالضلوع وراء الحادث
وتعهدت باحتفاظها بحق الرد في الوقت
والمكان المناسبين اما اوكرانيا فتنفي
وتقول ان هجوما كهذا لا يحقق لها اي هدف
وانها تعرف ان ذلك سيتسبب في رد فعل متطرف
والنفي الاوكراني ليس غريبا فمن قبل نفت
كييف هجمات كبيره كهذه كاستهداف جسر القرم
وتفجير خط الغاز نورت ستريم تحت البلطيق
الا ان روسيا ايضا تكذب هذه الروايات
الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
هذا واتهمت روسيا اوكرانيا بانها حاولت
مهاجمه الكرملين باستخدام سيارات في
محاوله الاغتيال الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين واعلنت رئاسه الروسيه اسقاط طائرتين
مسيرتين حاولت استهداف مقر رئاسه الروسيه
كما اعلن عمده موسكو
حذر استخدام اي طائرات مدنيه غير مصرح لها
في العاصمه
من جهته قال نائب رئيس مجلس الامن القومي
الروسي لمترمه لا خيار امام روسيا الان
بعد الهجوم على الكرملين سوى قتل الرئيس
الاوكراني
واعضاء حكومته قال او اضاف ايضا لا حاجه
لبقاء الرئيس الاوكراني على قيد الحياه
ليوقعها على استسلام اوكرانيا فدائما هناك
بديل على حد وصفه
الى ذلك قال الرئيس الاوكراني ان اوكرانيا
لا تهاجم بوتين او موسكو لكنها تقاتل على
اراضيها
ان بوتين زيف الهجوم من اجل تحفيز شعبه
للالتفاف حول حوله في الحرب رئيس اوكرانيا
قال ايضا ان بلاده لا تسعى لقتل ولكنها
تترك الامر للمحكمه في اشاره الى مذكره
اعتقال بوتين امام المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه والدعاء والاوكرانيه الاخرى بشان
ارتكاب جرائم حرب
هذه الرساله واعتقد انها ستكون على الاقل
مفهومه للجميع نحن لا نهاجم بوتين او
موسكو نحن نقاتل على اراضينا نحن ندافع عن
قرانا ومدننا ليست لدينا اسلحه كافيه لهذا
السبب لا نستخدمها في اي مكان لم نهاجم
بوتين لكننا نترك المجال للمحك مه
قبل ذلك قالت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ايضا
اللا علاقه لها بهجمات الطائرات من دون
طيار التي تعرض لها الكرملين وبانها تركز
حاليا على تحرير اراضيها التي تسيطر عليها
القوات الروسيه الرئاسه الاوكرانيه وصفت
التصريحات الروسيه بالخدعه وبانها مقدمه
لهجوم روسي شامل كما اشارت الى ان
المعارضه الروسيه قد تكون وراء الهجوم على
الارهابيه واسعه النطاق لذا دعونا نرى ما
الذي ستفعله روسيا اؤكد مره اخرى ان
مهاجمه بطائرات بدون طيار ليس هدفا
لاوكرانيا المشطه ووفق البيانات الصادره
عن الكرملين مرت سته عشره دقيقه بين هجمات
الطائرتين المسيرتين على مقر اقامه الرئيس
بلاديمير بوتين
في الساعه الثانيه هو 27 دقيقه صباحا
بتوقيت موسكو هجوم الطائره المسيره الاولى
انفجرت فوق قصر مجلس الشيوخ متسببه
باندلاع حريق على سطحه في الساعه الثانيه
وثلاث واربعين دقيقه هجوم الطائره
المسايره الثانيه سقط حطامها على اراضي
قصر الكرملين المسيرتان من نوع يو جي 22
صينيه الصنع
بعد الهجوم على الكريملين موسكو تمنع
طيران المسيرات في سماء العاصمه
الكريم
بمحاوله اغتيال فلاديمير بوتين مشيرا الى
انه لم يصاب باي اذن جراء الهجوم اوكرانيا
قالت ان لا علاقه لها بالهجوم وان اتهامات
روسيا مقدمه لعمل عسكري روسي شامل
الكريم انه يحتفظ بحق الرد في المكان
والزمان المناسبين مجلس الدومه يدعو
لتدمير نظام الكرملين
الامم المتحده قالت انه لا يمكن تاكيد
المعلومات الروسيه عن هجوم اوكراني على
الكرملين
مقر الرئاسه الروسيه تعرض لمحاوله هجوم
بطائرات مسيره اوكرانيه وفق ما اعلنت
موسكو
الكرملين كلمه تعني القلعه التي تحمي مركز
المدينه واهم الادارات فيها كل المدن
التاريخيه الروسيه تحتوي على كريمل خاص
بها المبنى ذو القبه الذي تابعنا لقطات له
هو مجلس شيوخ الكرملين الذي يطل على
الساحه الحمراء وهو اداره تابعه لرئاسه
الروسيه ويبعد قرابه 500 متر عن القصر
الرئاسي تابعنا لقطات الانفجار وكما اعلنت
موسكو فقد تم تعطيله وتفجير الطائرتين
المسيرتين بواسطه الدفاعات الالكترونيه في
الكرملين دون حدوث اضرار ماديه او بشريه
روسيا لم تعلن اي تفاصيل الا ان التحليلات
تشير الى ان الهجوم نفذ بواسطه مسيرات
تجاريه اطلقت من مسافه غير بعيده من شارع
مخوفايا غربال كرملين
[موسيقى]
معنى من كييف مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل
ومن امام الكرملين في موسكو كانت يطعمي
مراسله العربيه اهلا بكما ابدا معك كاتيا
هل هناك اي شيء تصريحا او تلميحا بانه
موسكو قد تتخذ قرارا سريعا بالرد يمكن ان
تكون بعض الملاحظات قد بلورت طبيعته
مرحبا طاهر حقيقه روسيا اولا كانت قد
تحدثت بعد هذا الهج
المتحدث الرسمي باسم
كان قد قال ان الرد طبعا سيكون من قبل
موسكو بتوقيت الذي تختاره وبالطريقه الذي
تختارها طبعا لكن لم يحدد ما هي الطريقه
او ما هو ما هي الرد الذي سيكون من الجانب
الروسي ولكن كما اعتدنا طاهر على روسيا
انها دائما تقوم بالرد على اي استهداف
وبالاخص بعد عده استهدافات كانت شهدتها
الاراضي الروسيه من بينها استهداف جسر
القرم كانت قد قامت روسيا بشكل مباشر
بالرد عسكريا باستهداف مباني وبنى تحتيه
وبالاضافه لذلك مستودعات الاسلحه بشكل
مكثف عندها وبالتالي يمكن التخمين هنا كما
تحدث بعض الخبراء العسكريين ان يكون الرد
هو بمثابه رد عسكري بقصف مكثف للاراضي
الاوكرانيه وبالتحديد يدعو ان تكون هذا
القصف هذه المره يعني يستهدف القصور
الرئاسيه يستهدف ربما اغتيال زيلينسكي
شخصيا يستهدف القضاء على النظام في كياب
وليس فقط مجرد رد محدود هل هناك اجماع على
ذلك في الداخل الروسي كل الدعوات تصب بنفس
ما قاله
وكذلك بعض
الممثلي الشعب
صحيح ما تقول طاهر هذه اللهجه الان تختلف
يعني اللهجات السابقه او كانت التصريحات
السابقه دائما تقول للسلطات الروسيه انها
لا تريد الاستهداف الرئيسي لينسكي ولا
تريد قتل او تصفيه الرئيس زيلنسكي ولكن
الان وبعد هذا الحادث اختلفت التصريحات
بشكل جذري هناك طبعا اولا من قبل مجلس
الدومه هناك كان دعوات بان يكون هناك قصف
مباشر لمقال الرئاسه الاوكرانيه بالاضافه
لذلك خرج نائب رئيس مجلس الدومه
ودعا الى ان يكون هناك او يتم قتل الرئيس
الرئيس الاوكراني زيلينسكي بعد استهداف
الرئيس الروسي وهو ما تعتبره موسكو على
لسان طبعا مسؤوليها هو بمثابه استهداف
لروسيا باكملها عندما تستهدف الرئيس
وبالتالي طبعا اللهجه اختلافات والدعوات
الان هي مختلفه هي لاصابه راس
النظام الاوكراني كما تقول موسكو باستهد
مساء الخير طاهر لك ولزميلك كاتيا في
الحقيقه كيف تبني دفاعها وايضا تنفي
مسؤوليتها حول هذا الاستهداف في عده نقاط
اولا كيف على لسان المسؤولين ابتداء من
الرئيس الذي قال بشكل واضح اننا لا نستهدف
الكريم
وايضا اشار الى انه حتى اننا لا نملك
السلاح الذي يمكننا ان نفعل به ذلك كذلك
يعني العدد من المسؤولين في اكييف ابتداء
من مستشاري الرئيس وزير الدفاع والرئيس
الامين العام لمجلس الامن والدفاع
الاوكراني جميعهم
ركزوا على نقاط محدده اول هذه النقاط هو
انه لا يوجد اي اهميه استراتيجيه من
استهداف بوتين او الكريم للداخل الاراضي
الروسيه هذا لن يحقق اي شيء على الجبهه
هذا لن يغير الوضع على الجبهه هذا لن يوقف
القتال هذا لن ينفي ان هنالك محاوله من
قبل الاتحاد الروسي كما قالوا طبعا لاح
الاراضي الاوكرانيه ولن يوقف القتال على
الجبهات هذا اولا لذلك لا يوجد اهميه
فائده على العكس تماما هذا سيجلب دوليا
وسيعطي مبررا للاتحاد الروسي لتنفيذ هجمات
داخل الاراضي الاوكرانيه اتجاه المدنيين
كما قالوا طبعا لذلك هم
ليسوا مسؤولين ولا يوجد اهميه من مثل ولكن
هناك بعض القراءات ان هذه دعايه وبالتالي
جزء من هذا بعض القراءات التي تتحدث عن
اراده كياب خلط الاوراق حتى لو لم تحقق
الكثير الا انها على الاقل لانها متورطه
بموضوع الهجوم المضاد وموعده ومدى قدرتها
الحقيقيه عليه تقوم بمثل هذا العمل لخلط
الاوراق الان خاصه بعدما حذرت الوثائق
الامريكيه السريه
كما كشفت كييف من من مدى خطوره وامكانيه
عدم احداث تقدم حقيقي في هذا الهجوم
المضاد
نعم طبعا كيف طاهر بشكل واضح حول الهجوم
المضاد اولا قالت انه يجب ان لا يرفع
الجميع سقف توقعاته حول هذا الهجوم المضاد
انه سيكون الاخير والحاسم وسيحرر الاراضي
الاوكرانيه بحسب هذا الهجوم قد يكون هجوم
فعال ولكن على الجميع ان ينتظر هجوم اخر
وثالث ورابع حتى تحرير كامل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه هذا ما صرح به وزير الخارجيه
الاوكرانيبا ايضا طبعا هم يقولون ان هذه
دعايه يعني
لترفع موسكو من مستوى العمليات العسكريه
والقتال والى مرحله جديده هي استهداف
مراكز صنع القرار هي استهداف الرئيس
زيليسكي ولذلك هذه دعايه من الكرملين يعني
هنالك مقدمات كما اشاروا لذلك وهو القبض
على عدد من ما سموه كما قالوا المخربين في
شبه جزيره القرم ونسبوا هذا ايضا الى كيف
وهذا الهجوم ايضا او كمسموه بالمسرحيه نحو
الكريم ايضا يقولون ان هذا مسرحيه سخيفه
يمكن للكرملين ان يستهدف اي طائرات مسيره
او اي هجوم نحو الكريملين من مسافه بعيده
جدا ولكنهم تركوا هذه المسيرات ان تصل الى
الكريملين وثم قاموا بهذه الدعايه هذه
الدعايه
خلينا نشوف اذا القوات الجويه وقال هذه
الدعايه خلينا نشوف مع كاتيا اذا عندها رد
من الجانب الروسي على هذه الدعايه واعود
اليك بعد قليل كاتيا هل هناك رد مباشر
بشان هذه النقطه تحديدا من بعض المسؤولين
الروس فيما يتعلق بكيفيه وصوله هاتين
المسيرتين لماذا لم تستهدف قبل وصولهما
الى الكرملين خاصه وانه كان في فاصل زمني
لا باس به بين المسيرتين والى ما هنالك من
هذه الامور اضافه الى الدعايه التي تحدث
عنها قبل قليل
زميلنا حذيفه بانه ما حصل ما هو الا دعايه
لتنقذ روسيا ربما لتشن حربا واسعه النطاق
على اكياف او على الاراضي الاوكرانيه
عموما ولكي تقوم بعمل مضاد او معاكس
للهجوم المضاد الاوكراني الذي يحكي عنه
استباقي
حقيقه طاهر يعني هو هذا الاستهداف اولا
بالطائرات المسيره يعني نشهده خلال الفتره
الاخيره بشكل مكثف على الاراضي الروسيه
ليست هي المره الاولى التي تصل فيها طائره
مسيره الى روسيا نعم هي تصل الى القلب
العاصمه الروسيه موسكو لاول مره ولكنها
استهدفت في سبق الضواحي العاصمه الروسيه
موسكو طبعا
الكرملين لم لم يشير او لم يتحدث لماذا لم
تقوم النظامات الدفاع الروسيه باستهداف
هذه الطائرات قبيله وصولها الى الكرملين
حتى الان لم يتم كشف عن الاسباب ولكن هناك
تحليلات كثيره من قبل الخبراء العسكريين
الذين تحدثوا اولا ان هذه ان هذه المسيرات
هي تم اطلاقها من مسافه قصيره من شمال
العاصمه الروسيه موسكو وانه تم استخدام
مسيرات قادره على الطيران لمسافه من 10
الى 20 كيلومتر كما تحدث بعد الخبراء
وان الانظمه الدفاع الجويه هي تستطيع ان
تلتقط على مسافه نحو 50 على ارتفاع 50 متر
ان تلتقط هذه المسيرات وبالتالي لربما كان
هناك
حذر خلال قياده هذه المسيرات بان تصل لان
لا تلتقطها هذه الانظمه الدفاعيه الجويه
كما تحدث طبعا الخبراء ولكن لا يوجد حتى
الان اي روايه رسميه بهذا الموضوع بهذا
الصدد لانها لانه تم استهدافها فقط عند
الكريم من قبل
الاجهزه استخبار الاستخباراتيه للكرملين
ولم يتم الكشف عن نوع هذه المستويات يعني
دائما كنا نشهد ايضا عند استهداف اي مسيره
لاراضي روسيه او مواقع في اراضي روسيا
كانت تتحدث دائما عن نوعيه هذه المسيرات
بانها اما تعود الى الحقبه السوفيتيه او
تم تحديثها او انها على سبيل البيرق دار
او اي نوع اخر تمتلكه القوات الاوكرانيه
ولكن الان لم يتم الكشف حتى الان عن نوع
هذا هذه المسيرات التي استهدفت الكريم
اعذريني حذيفه كاتي اشارت قبل قليل الى
انتشار امني مكثف بمحيط الكرملين ماذا عن
الجانب الاوكراني مما تلاحظوا في كييف او
مما يصلك من معلومات هل هناك اي تغيير في
طبيعه التعزيزات الامنيه
نعم طاهر لم يتغير شيء في كيف الوضع هذه
جدا المواطنين ايضا يتعاملوا مع الامر
بهدوء على الرغم من ذوي صفارات الانذار
مرتين اليوم بعد هذا الاعلان على الرغم من
ذلك المواطنين تعاملوا مع الامر بهدوء
اتام تعلم ان الرئيس الينسكي اليوم ليس في
البلاد ولكن يعني مكتب الرئيس هو ليس
ببعيد عن المكان الذي نحن فيه لم نلاحظ اي
تغيير في يعني الاجراءات الامنيه ولكن
لابد ان اشير هنا الى ان الاجراءات
الامنيه في محيط مكتب الرئيس فلاديميرازي
والبرلمان هذه المنطقه هي لم تتغير
الاجراءات الامنيه منذ اليوم الاول في
الحرب وحتى اليوم هي مشدده وكثيفه وقويه
وهنالك يعني حاجز واسع مضروب حول هذه
المباني ومراكز صنع القرار فلم يتغير شيء
حتى يعني انا هنا لا اتحدث فقط عن ان مكتب
الرئيس والشوارع المحيطه له ولكن حتى
الاحياء المحيطه لو هي مضروب حولها حاجز
امنيه حتى المواطنين الذين يسكنون في هذه
المناطق عليهم ان يستخرجوا تصاريح معينه
من جهاز الامن والمخابرات الوطني للمرور
من خلال هذه الحواجز للوصول الى منازلهم
لم يتغير في هذا شيء كذلك الوزارات يعني
انا الان اقف تماما بالقرب من مكتب الرئيس
اقف تماما خلف في البرلمان الاوكراني كذلك
وزاره
الداخليه الاوكرانيه فهنا يوجد مراكز صنع
القرار لا يوجد شيء لم يتغير شيء الحركه
كثير بشكل طبيعي كذلك لم نلاحظ اي انتشار
امني كثيف ولكن هنالك تحذيرات من
الدفاع الجوي بان لا يهمل المواطنين حالات
الانذار الجوي خوفا من ان يكون هنالك رده
فعل من قبل شكرا جزيلا لك حذيفه عادل
مراسل العربيه
من امام الكرام في موسكو تحياتي اليكم
[موسيقى]
قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
لا يمكنها التحقق من صحه تقارير تقارير
استهداف بوتين في مسيرات واضاف برينكن ان
امريكا تنظر بعين الريبه لكل ما يصدر عن
الكرامل واكد انها لا تعرف ما الذي حدث
هناك كما قال بالامكاننا قرارات اوكرانيا
لكيفيه دفاع عن نفسها تعود اليها وواشن
واثقه بان اوكرانيا ستنجح باستعاده ما
تبقى من اراضيها
لقد اطلعت على التقارير ولا يمكنني التحقق
من صحتها باي شكل من الاشكال فنحن ببساطه
لا نعرف اود ان اخذ اي شيء يخرج من
الكرملين بعين الريبه لذا دعنا نرى سنرى
ما هي الحقائق من الصعب حقا التعليق او
التكهن بهذه الامور دون معرفه الحقائق
اريد تسلايم مراسلات العربيه من واشنطن
تنضم الينا الان اهلا بك ريتا هل هناك اي
تصريحات اضافيه لما تقدم نقلا او على لسان
بلنكن
طبعا من الجدير ذكره بانه الولايات
المتحده تتعامل وتشدد على التعامل مع كل
ما
يبدر عن روسيا بكثير من الحذر ليس منكن
لوحده من صرح بهذا
المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض كريم جانبير
باجازها الصحفي اليومي
اكدت بانه ليس لدى الولايات المتحده اي
علم باي هجوم على الكريم او هجوم مخطط له
على الكريم وحتى
ذهبت للتعليق بعباره انه من الممكن ان
نكون نتعامل مع واقعه علم زائف اي وتقصد
بذلك انه قد يكون هذا الخبر
كاذب قد تقول روسيا ايضا عدد من المسؤولين
العسكريين شددوا بانهم ليسوا على علم باي
مخطط لتنفيذ هجوم من قبل اوكرانيا على
روسيا وهم دائما
يشجعون اوكرانيا على هذه الخطوه والقيام
باي هجوم خارج حدودها طبعا ذكرتم
تصريح الوزير بلينكن والذي قال ايضا بانه
يجب التعاطي دائما مع التصريحات الروسيه
باخذ جرعه من الملح وهو تعبير امريكي يقول
بانه قد يكون الامر فيه الكثير من
المغالطات الطاهر طيب لينكن ايضا بنفس
الفعاليه فعاليه اليوم العالمي لحريه
الصحافه تحدث عن يعني موضوع التسريب
الاخير لوثائق امريكيه كان من المفترض
انها بالغه السريه ويبدو انه يعني واشنطن
تبدو محرجه من تسريب مثل هذه الوثائق خاصه
بموضوع الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني المفترض
قريبا ماذا نملك من معلومات حول رد الفعل
الامريكي على الصعيد الرسمي حول هذا
التسريب وكيف تنوي واشنطن يعني ترقيعه اذا
صح التعبير
ساقول لك ما هي الاستراتيجيه التي تعتمدها
الاداره الامريكيه ايذاء هذه التسريبات
تحديدا يحاولون القول بانه لا يؤكدوها
طبعا
وحتى ذهبوا بالقول انه هذه التسريبات ربما
لا تكون صحيحه ونحن لا نلتزم بها في هذه
المرحله هم استمروا بتعاونهم الوثيق مع
الاوكرانيين ولم يتحدثوا على الاقل مع
الصحفيين باي خطط او استراتيجيات يتم
وضعها في المرحله المقبله على الاقل فيما
خاص اوكرانيا تحديدا الاداره الامريكيه لا
زالت تعلن عن مساعداتها لاوكرانيا مساعدات
الماديه والعسكريه ومن دون الحديث عن اي
خطط مستقبليه لاي هجوم من المفترض ان يكون
طبعا كل هذه الاحاديث من المسؤولين
الامريكيين مع الصحفيين تكون دائما مباشره
ولا ولا يكون هناك اي كتمان بالموضوع
عندما نسالهم اذا ما كان هناك اي خطط او
اي تعليق على هذه التسريبات دائما يشددون
بانه ليس هناك اي تعليق يعني الاداره
الامريكيه تحاول التعامل بحذر
للمرور فوق هذا الحقل
المليء بالالغام اذا مصحه التعبير طاهر
شكرا جزيلا لك سليمان مراسلات العربيه من
واشنطن تحياتي اليك
مع استمرار الحرب في اوكرانيا حاولت كياف
مرارا تخطي الفيتو الذي فرضه داعمها على
استهداف الاراضي الروسيه بواسطه الاسلحه
الغربيه بحسب الروايه الروسيه فان كييف
استهدفت العمق الروسي تدريجيا الى ان وصلت
الى النقطه صفر
الخطوط الحمر في نزاع روسيا واوكرانيا
بدات تنهار الواحده والاخر
وامام اعين من امنوا بان الحرب قد تحمل
بعض الاخلاق القادره على منع الفوضى
الشامله لم يخرج من مخباه في بدايه الحرب
الا بعد الحصول على ضمانات من روسيا بانها
لن تستهدفه كما قال رئيس وزراء اسرائيل
الاسبق نفطه ليبينت الشاهد على الاتفاق
وامريكا بدورها رفضت مرارا ضرب روسيا
بسلاحها وحتى استهداف وزير الدفاع روسيا
او رئيس اركانها في اوكرانيا الا ان كييف
التي تخوض حرب بقاء لم يتبقى لها الكثير
لتخسره وفيتو الحلفاء مرهون باستخدام
سلاحهم والحل لم تحمله الا اسلحه الروس
انفسهم
قبل اشهر
271 مسيره صوفيتيه سبق ظهورها المسيرات
الحديثه حلقت نحو الهدف على علو امطار
قليله في تحدي الرادارات ضربت اوكرانيا
قاعده انجلز على بعد اقل من 200 كيلومتر
من موسكو ثم قاعده اخرى في اليازان
الاضرار في كل مره لا تحسب بالخسائر
الماديه بل بوقعها المعنوي على الروس
الذين لا يفهموا الاوكراني حتى الان كيف
انهم لا يشعرون بالحرب على ابوابهم في
مرحله ثانيه شرعت اوكرانيا في استهداف
روسيا بمسيره سقط معظمها بعيدا عن موسكو
مسيرات تبدو غير متطوره لكنها فرضت على
الروس نشر انظمه الدفاع على مباني العاصمه
الشاهقه من معارك خرسون وزبروجيا تنقل
اوكرانيا المعركه داخل روسيا فيبريانسك
على الحدود وفي موسكو وضواحيها قبل ان
تستهد ف الكريم او ربما بوتين نفسه حسب
الروايه الرسميه الروسيه فيما رجحت وسائل
اعلام تنفيذ الهجوم بمسيره تجاريه صينيه
انطلقت من مكان غير بعيد عن الحادث فهل هي
بدايته هجوم اوكراني ام محاوله لافساد عيد
النصر على روسيا الا ان الاكيد هو تداعيه
الهجوم الذي قد يدخل الحرب مرحله حاول
الجميع تفاديها
الاوكراني
من المتوقع ان يتحدث في محكمه الجنايات
الدوليه في لاهاي يوم الغد الخميس وفقا
للحكومه الهولنديه طبعا سيغادر من المفترض
يعني في اي وقت ان يغادر هيلسنكي التي كان
فيها اليوم ليتحدث هناك غدا من ميخائيل
وساموس مدير شبكه الابحاث الجيو السياسيه
الجديده اهلا بك معنا استاذ ميخائيل في
هذه الساعه او التغطيه المستمره من
العربيه
ماء تبعات التي سيتركها هذا الهجوم بغض
النظر عن الاتهامات المتبادله اي مرحله
تدخل هذه الحرب بعده
ننظر الى هذه الاحداث
وكيفيه حدوثها يوم الامس
اقامه روسيا باطلاق اثني عشر مسيره ولم
نتفوه بشيء واذا كنت تطلب سؤالا من شخص ما
فلا بد لك ان تتوقع الجواب اننا نعد العده
للعمليه الهجوميه المضاده الاوكرانيه
المقبله وكل هذه الاحداث قد تكون مرتبطه
بعمليه الهجوم المضاده التي يتم تحضير لها
كصوره عامه لكن اذا كنتم تتحدثون عن
التبعات فلا استطيع ان اقول بانها
بان هذا الامر قد يكون قد نفذ من قبل احدى
الشركات العسكريه الخاصه في روسيا لان
هناك اعداد كبيره من الاوليجار الذين خاب
املهم باستراتيجيه الرئيس بوتين في حرب
اوكرانيا بسبب العقوبات واعداد كبيره من
هؤلاء الالب بات لديهم شركات عسكريه او
جيوش خاصه لذا لا استطيع ان استثني احدهم
من تنظيم هذا العمل الهجومي الذي يظهر
لبوتين بان تمت خطب ما قد يحدث هو انه
عليه ان يغير استراتيجيته وقف هذه الحرب
لان المشكله هي في داخل روسيا في حقيقه
الامر وليس في اوكرانيا او في النيتو او
ما شابه ذلك
المشاكل التي تحدث في روسيا تدل على تبعات
لعمليات القتال المختلفه التي تتم بين
الاشخاص الذين كانوا يتابعون لبوتون قلت
في بدايه ردك على السؤال الاول بانه روسيا
اطلقت اثنتي عشره مسيره بالامس ومن يدق
الباب عليه ان يسمع الجواب هذه المسيرات
هل استهدفت القصر الرئاسي الاوكراني مثلا
لكي تستهدف اوكرانيا ان فعلت هي بنفسها
القصر في في موسكو
اوكرانيا وبفضل قوات الدفاع الجويه
المتينه لديها فان كافه الصواريخ او
المسيرات الروسيه تم استعراضها
والبعض منها سقط خارج العاصمه الاوكرانيه
ومجموعه كبيره منها كانت قد ضربت اهداف من
بطن مثل مخازن للنفط في مدن اوكرانيا
مختلفه لكنني لا استطيع ان اقول الا ان
اقول ان بعض المسيرات التي
تم
استهداف اوكرانيا بها كان قد يرمى من
بالبعض منها استهدافي مكتبه لكن لكن لا
نعلم ما الذي قامت به قوات الدفاع الجويه
من استهدافه في مواجهات تلك الصواريخ
الروسيه
حتى الان بانه صار في استهداف مباشر
بمسيارات او بطائرات روسيه للقصر بالعكس
ما سمعناه كان في التزامات روسيه لجهات
دوليه بعدم استهداف زينسكي شخصيا هل باعتق
ادك بانه بعد هذا الحادث مثل هكذا
التزامات سقطت بمعنى ان موسكو ستكون في حل
من التزاماتها التي قطعتها لجهه الدوليه
بشان عدم اغتيال زيلينسكي
هل يعني سيكون بمقدورها وليس فقط بارادتها
هل سيكون بمقدورها ان تفعل ذلك
كما تعلمون المشكله التي تواجهها روسيا
بانه لم تعد قادره على اطلاق عمليه عسكريه
استراتيجيه فهي عالقه في وحل تلك المعركه
وما تزال
تعاني صعوبات جمه في السيطره على مدينه
مثل باخموت بل مقابل القوات الاوكرانيه
تعد العده لعمليه الهجوميه مضاده
والمبادره وزمام المبادره لدى القوات
الاوكرانيه في ظل هذه الظروف فان
القوات الروسيه قد تسعى لقتل الرئيسكي
وانا متاكد من نواياها لكنني امل بان قوات
الدفاع الاوكرانيه سوف تقوم بتامين
الحمايه اللازمه للرئيس وسوف تصبح الامور
على ما يرام وهل تعتقد بانزلنسكي سيقوم
بعد ما حصل بهجومه المضاد الذي قالت وثائق
كان مفترض انها سريه امريكيه بان الولايات
المتحده تخشى بشان حقيقه قدره الدفاعات
الجويه الاوكرانيه
ومن مدى ما يمكن ان يحققوا هكذا هجوم مضاد
هل تعتقد انه بعدها كذا هجوم يمكن ان
تتخلى كييف عن هذه الخطط
[موسيقى]
كلا لا اعتقد ذلك لان العمليه الهجوميه
المضاده سوف تكون
قائمه في ميدان المعركه في الجنوب وفي
الدمبس وفي اوكرانيا وهي غير مرتبطه
باي عمليات هجوميه سابقه قد جرت في
اوكرانيا ومنذ بضعه اسابيع حصلت اوكرانيا
اخيرا على المنظومه باتريوت الامريكيه
وباتا بمقدورنا الان ان ندمر كافه
الصواريخ الامريكيه حتى ليله الامس
وكان هناك موجه كبيره من الصواريخ التي
اطلقتها روسيا على العاصمه هذا يعني ان
القدرات الدفاعيه
الجويه الاوكرانيه
باتت في وضع جاهز وهذا سوف يغير من
المعادله فيما يخص الاعداد للعمليه
الهجوميه المضاده والشكه الحدوث
لتحقيق ماذا يعني هجوم مضاد لتحقيق ماذا
يعني كان الحديث في فتره من الفترات عن
مفاوضات عن امكانيه لانهاء الحرب خاصه وان
اوكرانيا طرف بغض النظر عن المعادله
العسكريه ولكن الشعب متاذن خاسر
لعيشه بسلام لماذا لا يكون العمل على هذا
الاطار وليس باتجاه هجوم مضاد من هنا او
من هناك
الهدف الحقيقي
هو الذي يحدده القائد الاعلى للقوات
الاوكرانيه وبوسعه ان اقول ان الهدف
الرئيسي او بالاحرى المهام الرئيسيه
لعمليه الهجوم المضاده سوف تكون اهداف عده
وليس هدفا واحده فهناك مساء لاستعاده
المناطق الاوكرانيه المحتله وانا متاكد من
شان عمليه في الجنوب لقطع الممرات بين
روسيا والقرن المهمه الثانيه قد تكون
استرجاع شبه جزيره القرن ودومباس هذه
المناطق شاسعه بطبيعه الحال ومهمه ليست
بيسيره وانا لست متاكدا اذا ما كان يمكن
انجازها
بضمن مظله واحده او ضمن عمليه واحده بل قد
تتجلى بمراحله مختلفه مثلا من تامين
القطعي الممرات وبعدها عمليه في دومباس
واخرى في شبه جزيره القرن فلنرى كيف سوف
تتجلب مراحل هذه العمليه الهجوميه المضاده
وتحقيق نجاح لكل منها
وهذا سوف يعمل على خلق كل مرحله منها سوف
تعمل على خلق الظروف المئاتيه للمرحله
التي سوف تليها وسوف نكون على اهبه
الاستعداد لكل منها الى ماذا تعتقد بان
زيلينسكي قادر على وضع خط فاصل
وعلى كشف الاجنحه المتعدده تحت قيادته
وكذلك العلاقه مع بعض اجهزه الغرب من
الدول الداعمه له كيف يمكن او الى اي مدى
يمكن له ان يفرق باعتقادك وان يميز بين
ارادته واراده شعبه واراده هذه الدول التي
تمده بالسلاح والمال
[موسيقى]
فيتمتع الرئيس
بقياده متميزه فالجنرزسكي ووزير الدفاع
السيد رزق
كلهم
يعملون مع الرئيس كفريقا واحد ولديهم
تنسيق واسع النطاق مع الحلفاء ومع الزملاء
من المملكه المتحده الولايات المتحده
فرنسا المانيا ودول اخرى وكما تعلمون
عمليات التنسيق
تعتمد على وجود خمسه عشر دوله تشارك في
دعمها لاوكرانيا
وهذا يرمي لخلق نوع من التنسيق
للدفع اوكرانيا للدفاع عن بلادها هناك
اكثر من خمسين دوله تنسق هذه العمليات هذا
يضرب مثالا جليا
عن النموذج الذي
تعتنقه
بدولها الخمسين ومن خلال وجود الرئيس في
سده السلطه فلابد لنا ان نثني على الفريق
الفعال الذي يعمل معه
ويسعى لتحقيق الرؤيه
التي يتم التطلع عليها لتحقيق الانتصار
لاوكرانيا
على عكس ذلك يقول اليوم لانه ليس هناك من
حاجه
لكي يوقع الاستسلام غير المشروط كما سماه
فهتلر لم يوقعه ايضا وروسيا على مشارف
يعني ايام قليله قبل الاحتفال بيوم النصر
في التاسع من مايو هتلر لم يوقعه ايضا
دائما يوجد بديل ويشير هنا الى الذي خلف
هتلر الا تعتقد بانه على كياف ان تفكر
الان
بتغيير
في في جلدها هي من الداخل قبل ان تغيره
موسكو من الخارج ان استطاعت
[موسيقى]
كما تعلمون لقد نفذت من الخيارات
كليا بشان هذه الاوضاع
ونعلم ان ان هتلر هو الذي قام بشن هجوم
على الاتحاد السوفيتي وليس العكس والان
نرى ان بوتين يجسد هتلر بعينه وقد يكون
النموذجا
للاحداث التاريخيه المعاصره والمتطوره
وهذه القصه تدفع على السخريه والضحك
واوكرانيا لن تقوم بتغيير اي سياساتها في
في مواجهه ما نسمعه لان هي التي قامت
باحتلال لمناطق اوكرانينيه
واخرجت الجنود منها ونحن نتعاون مع دول
اوروبيه في مواجهه روسيا الذي سيتحدث غدا
في محكمه الجنايات الدوليه في لاهاي ستكون
خطبه بعنوان لا سلام بدون عداله في
لاوكرانيا بدون عداله لاوكرانيا اذن شكرا
جزيلا لك مدير شبكه الابحاث الجيو
السياسيه الجديده تحياتي اليك والخارجيه
الامريكيه تقول للعربيه بانه اتهامات
روسيا لاوكرانيا بشان هجوم الكرملين سخيفه
[موسيقى]
دعا مجلس دوم الروسي لتوجيه رد قاسم على
محاوله استهداف الكرملين التي كانت تهدف
الاغتيال الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين حيث قام
باطلاق نداء لتدمير نظام بعد الهجوم على
مجلس الدوم الروسي بان الهجوم قال ان
الهجوم على الكرم لان سبب لاطلاق حرب
حقيقيه باوكرانيا وبان الوقت حان لاطلاق
هجوم صاروخيه على مقر اقامه الرئيس
الاوكراني
[موسيقى]
اكدت المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض كريم
جانبير ان واشنطن لا تشجع على استهداف
الاراضي الروسيه
لقد قلتها من قبل منذ بدايه النزاع في
اوكرانيا لا تشجع امريكا اوكرانيا على ضرب
روسيا خارجه حدودها ونحن واضحون بخصوص هذه
النقطه لكن اكرر مره اخرى اننا لا يمكننا
التحقق بخصوص صحه هذا التقرير ولذلك لا
يمكنني التعليق على الحادثه
اظهر مقطع الفيديو الذي نشره الكلام لما
يرجح انهما رجل امن كان يصعدان على قبه
المبنى قبل استهداف المسيره بثوان هذا
وقام بنشر فيديو لاستهداف الذي جرى فجر
اليوم بحسب تقديرات اوليه ولم يذكر ما اذا
كان لم يذكر ما اذا كان رجلان في مهم
امنيه الاعتراض المسيرتين او للتشويش
عليهما مثلا مؤكدا في بيان عدم وقوع اي
ضحايا او اضرار ماديه
رئيس مجموعه فاجنر قال ان اوكرانيا بدات
الان هجومها المضاد واضاف في بيان له عبر
تطبيق تيليجرام ان قواته لاحظت نشاطا غير
معهود للقوات الاوكرانيه على طول الجبهه
كما توقع ان تنتقل الاشتباكات الى مرحله
اكثر نشاطا في الايام القليله المقبله
من موسكو الكاتب السياسي بسام البني اهلا
بك معنا استاذ بسام كيف يفسر باعتقادك
وفقه متابعتك لهذا الحدث الكبير الفارق
الزمني بين المسيرتين سماح القوات الروسيه
بحصول ذلك اضافه الى وجود رجلي الامن على
القبه قبه المبنى الذي استهدف يعني ربما
اسعد الله مساءك ربما تكون صدفه وجودهم
كما يقومون بعمليه تنظيف للعالم او
للساريه العلم او شيء من هذا القبيل لانه
لا يمكن افتراض المسيرات باليدين يعني هل
يمكن ان يكون
صعب الى ظهر هذه القبه من اجل اعتراض
مسيره بيديهم وان كان هناك اعتراض
الكتروني فيمكن اعتراضهم من الارض لان
الالكترونيان يمكن الاعتراض على مسافات
شاسعه وليس من الضروري ان يصعدوا الى هذه
القبه هذا ما اعتقد والفارق الزمني بين
المسيرتين
يعني الفارق الزمني يبدو ان هناك كان خطه
من المخربين الذين اقاموا باطلاق هذه
المسيرات من شارع قريب من كما ذكرت انا في
فتره الظهيره على قناتكم ان هناك احتمال
ان يكون هناك استهداف من داخل روسيا يعني
او من داخل موسكو او من الريف المسكوفي
وقد اثبتت الاحداث ان الكريم اعلن ان
الاستهداف كان من شارع قريب من الكرملين
ما يعني ان هناك كان هناك خطه لاحداث ضرر
ما وبعدها الضرر ياتي بعد فتره بالمسيره
الاخرى هذا
تخطيط ارهابي بحث يعني
طيب بس لماذا تعتبر تخطيط ارهابي بحث كما
قالت موسكو لانه في احتمالات عده اولا ان
تكون تعرف يعني انه الاتهام بعض الاتهامات
تشير الى انه موسكو قد تكون مستفيده فتقوم
بتدبير هكذا عمل باجهزه امن او استخبارات
او ما شابه من مع روس في الداخل من
اوكرانيين متواجدين وهم بالملايين في
الاعلى الاراضي الروسيه في الداخل من
اجهزه متخبطه ببعضها البعض في الداخل ايضا
الى ما هنالك من السيناريوهات كيف يمكن ان
نتبنى نظريه ان اوكرانيا فعلتها والخارجيه
الامريكيه تقول العربيه قبل قليل بانه هذه
اتهامات سخيفه كل الاحتمالات وارده ولكن
السخف من من الخارجيه الامريكيه ان تقول
انها سخيفه روسيا اعلنت عن بدء تحقيق
جنائي في العمليه ولم يخرج نتيجه تحقيق
المؤشرات الاوليه تقول انه عمل ارهابي
اوكراني هذا كل ما في الامر روسيا حتى
الان لم تصدر يعني بيانها الرسمي الاكيد
حول نتيجه التحقيقات الجنائيه التي فتحتها
بناء على هذه العمليه اضف الى ذلك اننا لا
يمكن لنا ان نتصور ان يقوم يعني الروس
بضرب انفسهم على اعتاب
الاحتفال بنصر مايو بالحرب العالميه
الثانيه وضرب قمه الكريملين يعني لولا
قليل لسقط العلم من على فوق الكريمه وهذه
ضربه قاسيه لروسيا لا يمكن لروسيا ان تقوم
بها في الشارع محتقن دليل على ذلك الا ما
قاله البرلمان الروسي بانه يجب اتخاذ
قرارات حاسمه وسريعه لان البرلمان هو صوت
وضمير الشارع الروسي يعني
يظهر من خلال رد الفعل ومن النتائج لكي
نعرف من كان المستفيد الاكبر لانه في هجوم
مضاد يحكي عنه اوكراني قادم
رغم يعني المخاوف الامريكيه
حليفه اوكرانيا
وهناك ايضا بالتالي نوايا روسيه يعني كبح
جماحه او لوقفه قبل ان يبدا بالاحرى ربما
لتغيير مساره استاذ طاهر دعني اوضح نقطه
ان هناك قنوات موثوقه تطبيق التيليجرام
صرحت منذ ساعات من الان ان الهجوم المضاد
بدا بالفعل في منطقه ضواحي زبروجه باتجاه
زبروجه وهناك معارك شرسه تقوم هناك وبعد
قليل كما قلنا قبل قليل قال ذلك على
تيليجرام ايضا اعتبروا بدا يعني قال انه
في منطقه في المنطقه التي تعمل به قوته
انا اقول عن منطقه اخرى وهي ضواحي هذه
نقطه الشيء طيب
انه ما قبل استهداف الكريملين وما بعده
مختلف جدا وقد تغيرت قواعد اللعبه ويدي
روسيا مفتوحه اليوم ومنطلقه الى اي عمل
تقوم به للدفاع عن امنها واستقارها ربما
شو توقعاتك يعني ممكن نرسمها لقادم الايام
حول رد الفعل الروسي يعني اولا
لم يعد يستطيع ان يتجول كما يشاء قبل هذه
اثنين ربما يتم استهدافك فعلا شخصيا جسديا
وقتله وعصابه ايضا اوكرانيا لانه بكره
رايح على هولندا
اعتقد في داخل اوكرانيا لم تصل الامور الى
هذا الحد اضف الى ذلك ان هناك القنابل
المسيره التي تزن خمسه طن لم تستخدمها
روسيا حتى الان ربما يتم استخدامها على
القوات المتقدمه للهجوم المضاد الاوكرانيه
وكل هذه النقاط مهمه للغايه هذا ما قصدت
به بان قواعد اللعبه قد تغيرت عندما اعطى
بوتين
الضمانات حسب رئيس وزراء اسرائيل انه لن
يتم استهدافه خرج علينا من مخباه من الفوف
من غرب اوكرانيا وعاد الى كيف وبدا يعني
يستفز روسيا بشكل
متكرر هذا يعني اننا اليوم وبعد هذا
الاستهداف وانا اعتقد ان بوتين ليس لديه
امور شخصيه هو دائما يتحدث عن مصلحه البلد
بشكل عام هو عندما يتخذ قراره وقد سمعته
يوما يقول انني عندما اتخذ قراري اتخذ
قراري بناء على مصلحه بلدي وليس على مصالح
شخصيه بحته او على
بناء على
امور شخصيه بينما على مصلحه البلد وهذا له
عندما قال بعده انه لماذا لهذا العالم اذا
كان بدون روسيا عندما سئل عن انه هل
يستطيع ان يضرب نووي او لا فاجاب انه لا
مصلحه لي في هذا العالم دون روسيا وقد وضح
انه عندما يتخذ القرارات يتخذ قرارات بناء
على المصلحه الروسيه وليس على مصلحه شخصيه
طيب بالموضوع اللي كنت عم تحكي عنه قبل
قليل وكاله تاس تقول ان اوكرانيا فقدت نحو
30 جنديا ودبابه
اثناء الهجوم على
كان في عنا خبر قبل قليل مرتبط بالسودان
المنظمه التعاون الاسلامي تقول او تعقد
اجتماعا طارئا
لمناقشه تطورات السودانيه بناء على دعوه
من السعوديه اخر التطورات المتعلقه
بالعين على السودان وما يجري فيها ولكن
حدث الكرملين اليوم
اخذ كل الانظار في العالم وليس فقط في
عالمنا وهي وهو ما سيفتح مرحله جديده بدون
شك في العلاقه بين الطرفين في هذه الحرب
استاذ بسام البني الكاتب السياسيه عبر
سكات من موسكو شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المشاركه معنا تحياتي اليك
[موسيقى]
في تصريحات للعربيه قال نائب المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه نيثم ان واشنطن
لاوكرانيا باستهداف الكرملين تراها سخيفه
فيما حدث ليله امس ساترك التعليق للرئاسه
الاوكرانيه لكن لم يتم التحقق من
الاتهامات التي وجهتها روسيا بعد وكما ذكر
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انه لابد ان ننظر
في التصريحات الروسيه بقدر كبير من الشاك
فسياسه الولايات المتحده لطالما كانت
ترتكز على دعم اوكرانيا في الدفاع عن
اراضيها في وجه الغزو الروسي ويجب ان نذكر
ان اتهامات روسيا لاوكرانيا بشان هجوم
الكرملين سخيفه
وبينما تتعرض روسيا لضربات في قلبها في
موسكو تعاني من جزء حيوي اخر في الاطراف
في شبه جزيره القرم التي تتعرض لاستهدافات
اوكرانيا متكرره
تعهد قطعه عام 2014 عند ضم شبه جزيره
القرمه وانتزاعها من الخريطه الاوكرانيه
غير ان انفجارات وغارات جويه عده اظهرت
وفق اعلام غربيه هشاشه الوجود الروسي هناك
كما ابرزت شبه الجزيره كجزء من اهداف
اوكرانيا في هذه الحرب للتغلب على الرعب
من الضروري ان ننتصر في المعركه ضد
العدوان الروسي وان نحرر القرم
الضربات الاوكرانيه في عمق شبه جزيره
القرم ومن ضمنها استهداف مقر اسطول البحر
الاسود الروسي في سيفا ستوبول هدفها
استنزاف اللوجستيات ومراكز القياده
والسيطره اي تعطيل خطوط الامداد الروسيه
اولا كما تهدف لعرقله توغل موسكو جنوبي
اوكرانيا ومخططها البرمائي للاندفاع غربا
باتجاه اوداسا وانشاء جسر بري الى مولدوفا
الا ان الضربه الكبرى تمثلت بالانفجار
الذي هز الحيوي في اكتوبر 2022 ما ادى
لتدمير جزء منه وتعطيل حركه النقل وان
لفتره هذا الجسر هو الاطول في اوروبا
ويمتد لتسعه عشر كيلومترا بلغت تكلفه
ثلاثه مليارات وسته مئه مليون دولار ويعد
حلقه وصل بين شبه جزيره القرم ومنطقه
كريسنو دارك راي الروسيه شماليه القوقاز
نائب رئيس مجلس الدوما الروسي وصفاحينها
الانفجار بمثابه اعلان حرب في معدته
الخارجيه الروسيه دليلا على ما وصفته
الطبيعه الارهابيه للحكومه الاوكرانيه اما
مستشار زيلينسكي فاكد ان الانفجار مجرد
بدايه طالما ان كل شيء غير شرعي يجب
تدميره وفق تعبيره الضربات الاوكرانيه في
شبه الجزيره جاءت متقطعه على مدى اشهر الا
ان وثيرتها ازدادت بشكل كبير خلال الايام
الاخيره وهي وفق الوصف الروسيه تعتبر
اعمالا ارهابيه وتخريبيه يسعى لتفكيك شبكه
منفذها
صرح المفوض الاوروبيه تيار عن خطه ثلاثيه
الابعاد لتمويل حاجه اوكرانيا بالذخيره
للدفاع عن نفسها ضد روسيا بقيمه مليار
يورو حيث سيتم تمويل خطه انتاج الذخيره
اضافه الى توسيعها على الصعيد الاوروبي
خلال 12 شخص شهرا ناهيك عن تنظيم مشتريات
الذخيره بشكل جماعي بين شركات السلاح كما
ان المشروع سيطيح لاوكرانيا قرابه مليون
ذخيره لوقف النشاط العسكري الروسي
قال وزير الدفاع التركي خلصي اكارينا
نوابه وزراء دفاع روسيا واوكرانيا وتركيا
سيلتقون في اسطنبول يوم الجمعه المقبل
لمناقشه اتفاق يسمح بتصدير الحبوب
الاوكرانيه الى البحر الاسود
اتفقنا على اجتماع نواب وزراء الدفاع في
الخامس من مايو وخططنا لذلك خلال الاجتماع
ستتم مناقشه بعض القضايا بين البلدين بدءا
بصفقه الحبوب سنسعى لتمديد الاتفاق وحل كل
المشاكل ان وجدت هذه المبادره مهمه جدا
للدول المحتاجه للحبوب وهي مهمه ايضا
للسلام والاستقرار الاقليميين يمكننا
القول ان كلا الطرفين يتطلع بحراره الى
التمديد اتمنى ان تستمر هذه الصفقه دون اي
مشاكل
اذا الخارجيه الامريكيه تضيف للعربيه بان
التصريحات التي تاتي من الكرملين نتعامل
معها بشكوك المتحدث باسم الكرمله عندما
كان بشان صفقه الحبوب ان روسيا مهتمه
بتنفيذ جميع الاتفاقات في اطار صفقه
الحبوب هذه مؤكدا ان روسيا تواصل
الاتصالات في هذا الصدد وسط توقعات بان
تحقق شروطها كما ذكر باسكو بان الكراملان
لا يرى سببا حاضرا يدعو للتفاؤل بشان
اتمام صفقه تمديد مبادره تصدير الحبوب عبر
البحر الاسود
في المقابل اعلنت السلطات المحليه
الاوكرانيه فرض حظر تجول في خرسون الواقعه
قرب خط المواجهه اعتبارا من مساء الجمعه
ولمده 58 ساعه واوضح رئيس الاداره
العسكريه المحليه
على تيليجرام انه وخلال حظر التجول سيمنع
التنقل في شوارع المدينه هذا بشان اذا اخر
التطورات في تلك المنطقه في خرسون تحديدا
عسكريا وميدانيا نعود لنذكر
بحدث الساعه وحدث اليوم الاساسي وهو
الهجوم بمسيارتين على
الساعه الثانيه وسبعه وعشرين دقيقه صباحا
بتوقيت موسكو هجوم الطائره المسيره الاولى
انفجرت فوق قصر مجلس الشيوخ متسببه
باندلاع حريق على سطحه في الساعه الثانيه
وثلاثه واربعين دقيقه هجوم الطائره
المسايره الثانيه سقط حطامها على اراضي
قصر الكرملين المسيرتان من نوعيو جي 22
صينيه الصنع
بعد الهجوم على الكرملين موسكو تمنع طيران
المسيرات في سماء العاصمه
الكريملين اتهم بمحاوله اغتيال فلاديمير
بوتين مشيرا الى انه لم يصاب باي اذن جراء
الهجوم اوكرانيا قالت ان لا علاقه لها
بالهجوم وان اتهامات روسيا مقدمه لعمل
عسكري روسي شامل
الكريم قال انه يحتفظ بحق الرد في المكان
والزمان المناسبين مجلس الدوما يدعو
لتدمير نظام
قال ان واشنطن تنظر بالريبه لكل ما يصدر
عن الكريم
الامم المتحده قالت انه لا يمكن تاكيد
المعلومات الروسيه عن هجوم اوكراني على
الكرملين
التغطيه مستمره من العربيه بعد قليل ولكن
مع زميل ميسون
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات